il faut aimer aux bâtiments scolaires
ils sont pleins de souvenirs pleins de
rêveries d'un monde idéalisé robichaud
plus grande imagination
ce sont 190 élèves de maternelle et 260
élèves de primaire qui arpentent les
couloirs chaque jour de la toute
nouvelle école thomas pesquet de
villepreux
la ville a inauguré vendredi 18 juin
dernier c'est un bijou architectural et
environnemental s'est elle fait partie
de cette nouvelle génération d'écoles
construites avec des briques en terre
cuite locale avec justement une cour
végétalisée en tout cas avec des
matériaux aussi biosourcés donc c'est
une très belle école aujourd'hui c'est
un endroit qui est là aussi pour rendre
les rêves des enfants ville plusieurs
réalités
le projet avait été initié en 2018 par
l'ancienne municipalité entre retards de
chantier et pandémie mondiale
le groupe scolaire a pu ouvrir ses
portes en février dernier pour marquer
le coup la ville a fait participer ses
habitants pour choisir le nom de cette
école tant attendu pour répondre à ce
temps d'attentes
il fallait créer quelque chose autour de
cette école et donc on a décidé dans la
logique participative qui est la nôtre
de lancer cette consultation citoyenne
et il s'avère finalement que c'est le
nom proposé par les enfants qui ont
intégré l'école parce qu'ils étaient
dans d'autres écoles jusqu'à lors ils
ont proposé avec leur enseignant le nom
de thomas pesquet et au terme de cette
consultation citoyenne qui a rassemblé
un certain nombre de votants c'est ce
nom là qu'il l'a emporté mais je crois
entre nous qu'il était difficilement
battable 11,7 millions d'euros ont été
nécessaires pour la construction de ce
nouveau groupe scolaire un coup presque
intégralement financée par la commune
avec l'appui de la région du département
ainsi que de la caisse d'allocations
familiales